okay so there's an entire betting site
in china
where people can bet on whether or not a
league of legends pro
will win or lose their solo queue game
on
stream the thing is the teammates of
those pro players
are being contacted by the betters to
intentionally throw their games
the players win big and the betters win
even
more believe it or not people are being
paid to throw
fakers games on stream
[Music]
okay just before we get into that i'm
gonna point you guys towards the
subscribe button
if you haven't subscribed already what
are you waiting for we are on the road
here
to 2 million subs incredible number
we're really excited so please
help us get there if you haven't
subscribed already first things first
illegal gambling sites have been a thing
in china for
years now covering both traditional
sports and esports
but this is something different people
are apparently betting on streamers
including pros to lose their solo queue
games
and bribing their teammates to throw
them because obviously it's a lot easier
to get someone to throw a random solo
queue game than it is to get a sports
team to throw a professional game
and that is where these sites have swept
in i spoke to olay who alleges that the
people throwing these games are playing
from
china on the korean server more from him
later
korean players affected by this have
been looking to write for a solution
and on monday riot responded in a
statement translated by inven global
they said we've confirmed that a number
of players overseas have been involved
with illegal chinese esports gambling
websites to directly influence the win
loss of lck pros and that they've
illegally used korean accounts in the
process
the statement also said that riot had
inspected
10 000 high elo accounts in south korea
and had deactivated all accounts that
were suspected
of being illegally used overseas those
foreign accounts were apparently using
third-party software in order to lower
their ping to be able to play
on the south korean server and so riot
has implemented
a real-time solution in order to detect
those programs
all accounts found using third-party
programs will be suspended within
three minutes of a game beginning and
their teammates will be given the option
to remake the game
essentially they're hoping to stop the
match fixing by
blocking the players who are throwing
games from even being able to
access the korean server now to
understand just how we got here we need
to go back to the beginning
last week olay sent out a tweet saying
in china
there is illegal betting on pro queue
and
abusers who intend to throw games to
make money
especially faker is the biggest victim
among streamers
who knows n a eu solo q have the same
thing
he also showed a video from a korean
streamer called minsik park
who showed an app that listed korean
pros and streamers that were streaming
at that moment with what is supposedly
an option to place
bets on those games there was t1 curse
uzi and faker himself so i reached out
to olay to find out more
he returned to south korea from north
america in
june and said it was while he was
watching faker's stream one day that he
noticed something was
seriously wrong i saw his one game was
like he's
he was playing really very mid and then
he's like both you just like randomly
like through the game all the time
like like and then the chat was like why
they're
throwing it's like you have faker in
your team and that you
kind of like 70 percent gonna win
because you have faker
right but it's like they really like
literally throw all the time
now we've all seen people throw games
before maybe even intentionally but olay
felt like this was something different
like he said
playing with faker is like the closest
thing you can get to a free win so why
would anyone want to throw that away
olay eventually found park's video park
tried to access the chinese site yabo
one of the alleged betting sites from
his south korean browser
he was met with this error message so he
used his
chinese friends login details on the app
to show his viewers
what it looked like and league wasn't
even the only game on there
for these clips we're using the english
youtube translation from the original
video
lol
he then finds a page which shows
streamers playing
at that moment including t1's jungler
cuz
foreign and those numbers are what this
whole story
really revolves around here because
obviously the odds are going to be
skewed in favor of some of the best
players on the planet
pro player usually have like 55 to 60
relate
so usually losing has more like losing
can make more money
you can see where this is going right
the assertion here
is that players hard throwing streamers
games including fakers
is no accident they're being offered
money to do it as soon as the betting
abusers can see
that streamers teammates in champ select
and even more than that olay thinks the
money that you can win from these kinds
of bets
is relative to how big the streamer is
faker stream is most popular because
there's like so many people there and
then
because there are so many people the
money pie is so big
like if i'm kind of like a chinese like
illegal guy
i'm going to throw my 100k and the
battle faker gonna lose
and then i'm gonna ask the opposite hey
just lose the game then i make 100k for
free because it's two times
so it's basically 100 stock
when elo boosting became a problem in
korea the government
cracked down on it and made it illegal
they targeted boosting companies and
heavily fined any players that
interacted with them
with this betting situation though olay
says it's become more difficult to deal
with because
the players that are throwing games on
the korean server
are playing from china so they're
outside the country's jurisdiction
the problem is if chinese people abuse
it in korea we have no way to
you know let them go to jail or
something you know if you're a streamer
who's getting their game thrown by a
teammate for money
that already seriously hurts your
content but for a pro player
solo queue is the bread and butter that
they use to
sharpen their mechanics and practice new
champions and items
with people throwing their games they
can't get in the high quality practice
that the korean server is famous for
like if i like if i play like this and
your team just throw the game you can't
practice and then
you turn to be a tool for those you know
betting guys
and the second is pro player can't
actually
practice much because those sys those
betting guys just come up our games we
even though we try hard we gonna lose or
we gonna win for free
you know i think that's really dumb now
as i told you guys at the start of the
video riot has
implemented software to catch and
suspend these foreign accounts within
minutes of joining a game and in a
different statement
last week they also said they've set up
a hotline for lck pros to contact ray if
they
ever run into users they suspect of
intentional match fixing
between those two solutions raya are
hoping to bring an
end to this match fixing which will no
doubt come as welcome news to
many pros and streamers out there
especially faker
it's just so funny to me especially in
the intro
how similar your cadence is to jeremy
clarkson from top gear
and like i have this i don't think this
is true but i have this
weird memory of you telling me that you
watched a lot of top gear as a kid
and that's where you got the uh the like
what the intonations from but clearly
this did not happen right
i did watch top gear as a kid
but i never i never idolized jeremy
clarkson i think he's i think he's a bit
of a
[ __ ] to be honest i think it's probably
just like british presenting style like
i know what like the north american
presenting style would be like we'll
have that update for you
when it comes if riot successfully
cracked down on this
it could be the biggest thing in a
lifetime
you know dude that was amazing holy